you probably don't want to be normal
because if you take what normal means
and put it across all aspects of life it
means that you're going to die at 74
you're probably gonna be overweight be
divorce you're gonna not really achieve
anything that you want like that's
normal and so it makes sense that you
would be the odd man out because most
people live that life that was something
that gave me a lot of permission to like
be me which was not normal and that's
okay because I mean like ordinary versus
extraordinary means that you are not
that feeling of loneliness makes you
normal in the right rooms that's exactly
right